in five four three two one or lie
everybody come on I mean Hoss
hey do you speak Spanish Topher oh boy
your voice whitewash it's not even funny
what kind of finish so my papa is
Salvadorian my mom is whiter than a
[ __ ] right I guess the story is
do you guys hear that yeah my throat
sound like you ate a frog and it died in
the world so anyway so my mom my dad
Salvadorian this is a story I was told
he was speaking to me in Spanish when I
was a kid I was starting to learn it but
then I was having a hard time speaking
English when I was in school so he
stopped no I mean I couldn't really
speak English that well either though
but they put you in the ESL class and
that [ __ ] all evens out
yeah where she wouldn't stop but you
know my dad wasn't like my dad I don't
know maybe my dad wasn't really a
citizen citizen he was able to work here
but if I say my dad was really dumb no
no no I don't I don't know maybe I think
he probably felt a different type of way
right he probably like I want to make
sure my son can speak English yeah um so
my parents dude yeah so my parent I wish
I knew Spanish like obvious I don't like
the stupid [ __ ] right like pinky and
pendejo and no mamas way yeah
oh that's have a [ __ ] but I can't it's a
lot of parents have this weird fear like
their kid not being able to speak
English here's the thing you live in
[ __ ] America the kid is going to
learn how to speak English either a
matter way no matter what and especially
in this country when it comes to jobs
yeah and kind of standing out being
bilingual at an early age when you
absorb knowledge the best is the best
thing on earth I know some kids that are
born here that have like fabulous like
they speak with the craziest accident
yeah bet you still understand them
though
nah dude really like it's bad okay well
shout out to this girl let's just set up
okay this is girl in high school right
yeah let's just hurt say her name I'm
not gonna say her name because I think
cuz sacrum is a very small town so
everybody
and I yeah I think we're still friends
and they're on lockdown right now too so
she probably goes yeah she probably sure
right but this girl can cannot speak
English to save her [ __ ] life so I
went back to sac a few years back and
then we met up again right when you're
around somebody who has [ __ ] up
English and your homies and you just
kickin it every day you understand it
like you somehow decide for that [ __ ]
when they speak I saw her like a few
years back and at a Christmas party that
we have this I thought this [ __ ] has
CTE James Tony hold on a second what the
[ __ ] is she say David like she's talking
second one of my homegirls like she's
really good friends with her
she's like punching me in the leg
because I'm trying not to laugh in her
face I couldn't understand a [ __ ]
word she's saying and you've been gone
for so long I just I did just like
you're not used to her the way she's I
didn't realize her English was so bad
and that even goes back to this other
homie his name is oh just calm JP JP has
a thick Filipino accent had no [ __ ]
idea
yeah I'm just around it all the time we
all know someone like that yeah no lego
Akko oh I love Akkad to death but
sometimes he says [ __ ] I'm like yo
shout-out to all of Akko I just don't
know what he says sometimes but when I
was training with him more frequently I
started be like AK I know what he's
saying
Rococo is the most famous man in
Pasadena kawaii knows who he is no and
he's not even from Hawaii that's the
crazy post so nice that he knows
everybody
dude so what are we so Elliott shoutout
to the huh me Elliot
he was in Texas and he was gonna school
out there and Akko is Micronesian mm-hmm
he met Anne Elliot when he was in Texas
he met this dude who is Micronesian and
he goes hey man that's crazy like I only
know one other Micronesian dude and he's
back in California and the Micronesian
guy in Texas goes a is a acha acha
harlem and he goes yeah dude what though
please dude as well nicest dudes I've
ever met
super cool he kind of sounds like the
one Cajun dude in Bobby Boucher so Akko
is a coach that trains a fight Academy's
a really good coach and he's a really
good dude like probably one of the most
like he'll he'll literally give you his
t-shirt off his back he'll literally
give you his tie shorts off of his body
like no bro put your pants back on I
love you but my homies uh he was like yo
dude I see this Mexican dude LA Fitness
and he's he's always playing ball and
he's always wanted a fight academy
hoodie you know who he is and I was like
I have no idea that's like you'd worse
it just yeah Mexican doing a fight he
goes but he sounds Hawaiian and I'm like
oh oh go boom ah Co that's exactly who
it is but everybody knows the dude
you know best dude around ah Co has his
fights on [ __ ] you ass you know I've
watched his only then choke somebody out
and should put our marks they put him in
like the weirdest [ __ ] armbar - yeah
for my memory but like yeah and
everybody in the crowd is going bananas
dude he probably had like 90 hundred
people's a cat Socko that's a knocko
number right I love can't even imitate
how he how he sounds now beretta yeah
and his brother that's right brother
like he'll be saying some like when I
was at gym he be say some and then
finish of a right Alex and I feel like
yeah true taco also saw me when I was
like the biggest and he would always say
that he would see me get smaller and
smaller and smaller the first time that
I kind of experienced probably how he's
kind of like in his classes was when I
have a video of me learning how to do a
switch kick and he was using the kick
shield for the first time and then just
I was just screaming in the back
ultimate hype man they go Tech ACOs
classified Academy like I think it's
Monday was after I don't know the quorum
guys make sure you don't got corner when
he go yeah but that dude runs such a
good group class like everyone goes and
it's all I got Monday Wednesday at noon
at my Monday I've got allowed in and
then Wednesday at noon people like him
so much
I've seen the same people there even
after we left fine Academy there's still
a class and they've been there for two
years
and they were already there before I was
that's how much they love och oh yeah
Baco so much but week but today topic
and we're actually talk about this
[ __ ] love life did let me tell
you something man you know I've always
talked about on podcast how sometimes
with people like their they tend to be a
little too shy most timid human being
when it comes to women and I don't
understand why but then you lift 700
pounds often why are you so scared of
women I just say I'll speak for Alex I
think for Alex he's such a good nice guy
he doesn't want to come off as weird
creepy a creepy as a girl so it's like
forty old virgin where he's like I
respect women so much I completely stay
away from let me just tell you that's
part of me just tell you this quick
scenario right and mind you I'm not I'm
not a savant when it comes to women
either right but I feel like I can
navigate myself away a way around a
conversation that anybody could do a
little better than you know
then our boy Alex Alex like he doesn't
even take the shot case in point
case in point real quick that was Alex
was supposed to go out on a date with
his girl right and then she says that
her car isn't working her car breaks
down or whatever and he's like okay cool
so now typically when a guy would say if
he has a functioning car and what she's
actually hinting at is hey my car is
broken down maybe your car's not even
broken down because what she actually
wants is for the guy to come pick her up
my man what did you say to her
alright so let me
question what did you say to her in the
response after she said my car is not
working I said I if we need a reschedule
hey but there's backstory no I know but
if you explained the backstory it'll
make it even funnier dude well the whole
thing for me is like when we set up this
day she hit me what she hit me with that
like oh I'll meet you there
so in my head immediately I might okay
she doesn't want me to pick her up
that's what I thought so I my alright
[ __ ] right so that all the [ __ ] happened
with a car and she's like yeah you know
my car's this my car is that and I'm
just like alright then bed like I guess
schedule and then her response was yeah
right so I want me finish the story so
yeah so it was funny because I was with
Nick and David during this time we we
just went to it was like Chinese New
Year right or some [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
so then I remember telling them in the
car like on even both of them I even
texted my homie Patrick and he was like
eight offered it pick her up
I'm like nah nah she wants to drive so
I'm not gonna bro it was so set on that
too yeah so like later on the restaurant
we were supposed to go to actually went
with my mom right to go eat and I posted
a picture and she responded to it and I
do this a lot to you what does she say
she was she just said damn right and I
do this a lot like in my head I'm like
you know what [ __ ] I'm a golfer let
me see what happens and I do that and
then I'd say about 90% of the time I
still don't do it but like there's like
a 10% that I feel it and then saw like
[ __ ] I'm gonna see what she says so
I'm like yeah man I guess I could have
just offered to pick you up her response
was yeah I definitely would away
that's exactly that's exactly she was
dancing yet and that's the funny part is
like that's that in and of itself
encapsulate how you are with women which
is so [ __ ] funny I got I get all my
girls that I've died and I've gotten so
lucky with because they started like
I've never yeah I've never had to like
start the relationship the girl I always
came on to me and like they kind of
started it up so I'm like [ __ ] this is
good the only problematic to speak and
the reason why I got at this is because
but he talks about like his interaction
with women right and it's it's so odd
because of how awkward it is because he
can't get out of his own [ __ ] head
yeah which we always talk about this in
this podcast where there's a human being
where I get messages it's not yours is
actually mild compared to some of these
other kids but sometimes like you have
these thoughts in your heads that kind
of just grow into this weird weird
thought of how bad things are gonna
happen and it never ever gets that way
and it's also we know who you are and we
notify in person and it's like dude you
were so overthinking it for you I'm not
anything that's that's what I'm saying
this guy his first fight when he found
out when he told me who he was fighting
he was like all find his big-ass black
dude in my head I was like oh [ __ ]
and he show me who the guy was and I was
like oh man this guy's 6:4 alex is like
five seven five six and I was like yo
this [ __ ] big is shittin in my
head I was like all right bro like this
is gonna be a trip but when I was like
how you feel he goes I'm fine and
usually when I hear people say I'm fine
I usually don't believe it but this time
I was like oh [ __ ] this dude's actually
like chill so it made me feel a way more
relaxed but the fact that this dude is
so calm when he's gonna fight another
human being in front of like hundreds of
people and then he can't even be like
hey I'll pick you up
that's how always the most ridiculous
thing ever I think it's that I don't
know it's like I've never been confident
in myself in my looks basically was my
looks like growing up like I was like I
I don't feel a job dude I was always
kind of chunky I just never had the
confidence so like talking to girls was
always something more it was terror
lying to me and there would be so many
situations where like like if someone
else was watching it they'd be like yo
that was like your opportunity and I
would just it would just what should
what what are you scared of though was
the question you know I honestly I think
I've been scared so long I don't even
know what I'm saying
everything it's like you know growing up
I was scared of getting rejected I was
for some reason scared that they were
gonna say no and then everybody was
gonna find out and then I'm the
laughingstock of all this girl turned
him down laughingstock see see now this
is what I want to bring up and I knew
that [ __ ] was gonna come on now I'm
gonna use his girl as an example I'm not
gonna say her name but she was saying
something very similar to this and then
you have this issue that a lot of people
have and take this with a grain of salt
you're not that [ __ ] important like
yeah nobody nobody [ __ ] cares told me
the same thing this is what I always
tell but this is my saying now it's like
you're an you are an important human
being but you're not that [ __ ]
important yeah and that's the biggest
thing that people have to take away from
this it's like you do this right a girl
rejects you it's same aha you move on it
is what it is yeah nothing's gonna
happen but a lot of the times when some
guys get rejected if they're not used to
getting rejected like your boy here haha
scatter ha it eats away at you you start
going to the start of like damn like I
just embarrassed myself she's gonna be
talking [ __ ] about me to her [ __ ]
friends about that [ __ ] loser guy
yeah that was always my thing in my I
already know yeah it was always my thing
I was always so nervous about that and
it was just like came down to look so I
like I was like oh I don't look good
with my shirt off like like in my head
when I was younger I'm like how am I
supposed to date this girl and then like
eventually like I've had to take my
shirt off in front of her I won't even
have the balls to do it and [ __ ] it
would not be so nervous it's not a
[ __ ] the dark man
but there were certain I remember and it
was just [ __ ] that would happen to me
right that would like I wasn't good at
reading these queue so I would think
that these girls were into me and I was
completely wrong and I remember I
remember in high school my senior years
when I finally lost some weight right I
was working out and stuff so I started
feeling more confident and then finally
you know I was like you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] try this [ __ ] right I'm gonna
ask a girl out whatever like that you
just took your shirt off right
see my chest so like I remember what it
was I won't say the girl's name Isis I
don't know I still know her and
everything like that but say her name's
there now
what is it no no no that's not starts
with an A if people from our old school
know like mommies enough but anyways
like it was one of those dances you know
like there was like 45 [ __ ] dances
right it was my senior year and I was in
shape and she like wanted to start
working out with me and we were talking
a lot more like I was going her house on
my oh she's into me right so I was like
you know what [ __ ] I'm doing on this
day I was one of the only people had a
car so I would taking her home one day
and I stopped and I asked her out to the
dance and this was her response and this
is what I've always been terrified of my
whole life after after it was um I have
to let you know he and I were getting my
face like I was so embarrassed my face
was so high oh and my body was so hot my
hand started sweating and [ __ ] and I was
just like okay for sure and she got on
my car and I felt like the biggest dumb
ass in the world drive like I was so
pissed off of myself I was like you're
[ __ ] stupid why'd you [ __ ] add
water a lot of people can relate to that
feeling yeah and I was like why'd you
ask her why'd you [ __ ] do that a
story like that too with TIFF yeah and
then so when what made it worse right is
like one of the kids we hung out with
the reason why she was saying that it's
cuz the other kid asked her and she
wanted to go with him instead so she
said yes to him and he was friends with
our group so I'm just like [ __ ] see but
if you if you the funny thing is that
that mean the way you tell the way you
tell this story it's like it happened
yesterday
yeah and so it still affects you here's
the thing when you tell that story to me
all I hear was this guy asked the girl
out and she just got asked out before
the way you described it sounds like
like a [ __ ] kung fu movie right where
some [ __ ] was about to go down in a
super villain kr yeah the night came the
wind we're story you told us we're like
Kill Bill dude yeah it was literally you
asked a girl out to a date but she was
already called for your this ass that's
all that it is there's so many missed
opportunities I know of that I just I
never had the balls and still to this
day
even make jokes you am IA invite this
person to this okay let me just tell you
this right my best friend my best friend
did the most [ __ ] up big ever so what
are the home girls went up to it right
so this is a girl that I haven't this
within our group she's [ __ ] weird
still weird to this [ __ ] day she
knows who she is if you're listening to
this [ __ ] you're [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
odd be like true she had a cushy I mean
she had a crush on everybody in the
group that's how weird she was like this
girl just she she likes you talk about
shooting your shot she was shoot her
shot to everybody like so you want to
[ __ ] one of our friends went up to my
best friend and then asked her asked him
he goes she goes hey so she so I have a
friend ba ba bla like this girl's name
she needs a she needs a date to prom
right
this [ __ ] on the spot goes like
that dog she's standing right behind it
[Music]
that's right that's what I would be
terrified of half oh so I mean you talk
about your situation your situation is
not even bad but man let you say ill
when you eat food that's accidentally
spoiled yeah what it what happened after
that what happened she just stood there
and then she kind of laughed it off
because she's a very awkward girl but
I'm pretty sure she started you know
cutting her hair in a room like I used
to be like oh ha ha like oh yeah totally
yeah and I think I think because of the
way a lot of my relationships were they
weren't like the best relationships but
you but you still had relationships I
know and lo had you've had like eight
different girlfriend like long-term and
I don't mean it like I don't I don't
and here's the thing too when we were
talking about this earlier he was
talking about this other girl that he
was talking about I'm not sure if it was
the same girl but he was like I'm so
nervous around here blah blah blah and I
saw a picture of her and I'm not saying
that she's not beautiful but what I'm
saying is she was a little walk yeah and
what I mean by whack I mean she just
looked like a very beautiful average hey
there and I get told this all the time
right because I don't have I have zero
game when it comes to girls I have zero
game we're gonna do a scenario right now
I think you're the girl and Alex you're
you I'm already like nervous
now we got it we got to do a scenarios
we got to fix these habits right now on
this podcast here we go so Nick you are
a girl yeah yeah Adam on mission fitness
okay right
that was now yeah now you I in him real
quick cut and you could kind of notice
that she's looking at you and they're
just you were gonna ask him about
workout advice now this right here I'm
giving you a scenario at a clear sign
that she's interested in you because she
walked over to you and asked you about
workout advice when there's a thousand
other people in gym working out all
right and ready to go hey Alex I just
know you're really strong and thanks I
like iseas squat so I was wondering if
you could just help me out with like my
squat cuz it's like you know it's like
not that good yeah definitely like what
what's wrong with your squat like what
are you feeling is incorrect with it I
just feel like the bottom I just can't
get over the whole that well so if you
could just help me yeah so here I'll
stand in the front just so it's not
awkward or anything
I stand in the front and watch you do
your squat so I can go ahead and fix
your cubes well I feel like you should
probably stand behind me because it's
the way it's pretty heavy so you should
slow it later let's lighten it down a
little bit just so you can do it
yourself and I can watch well I think
you should still stand behind me and so
I was able to check your four so right
now so right now have Alex set up from
the seat that seat would be orange from
this way no so here's the thing that
this is why that scenario would it
really work for me because immediately
in my head I wouldn't go that much mode
coach mode I wouldn't know that she's
into me so I wouldn't even any other
time where you could think in your head
or possibly because I know guys always
think like oh dude you totally into me
oh yeah but like has there been times
where a girl has approached you for like
coaching advice and you in your head
you're like maybe she was into me yeah
maybe she was like a cry for just kind
of talking there's been a couple of
times for that and
like I was like [ __ ] because you know
the girl was attractive and I like they
thought they were cool and I was like
are I [ __ ] that chance up because I
went straight into coach mode but what
you were kind of leading to I was saying
yes was that there's been one time in my
life and it just happened where I was
like oh that girl was like and it was
like a clear sunny yeah so basically
we're talking whenever like that
conversation comes down to where it's
like it's coming to an end right and she
starts asked me like questions and stuff
and it comes to and she's like yeah and
my friend Jessie's there right and I'm
like yeah and then we just start staring
at each other and it's about eight
seconds go by and then she goes okay
yeah so maybe I'll see you around I was
like yeah I'll definitely see you around
I want you to [ __ ] go outside and
then lay in front of a car listen let me
just say this okay in in my history of
dating because of how weird I look as a
human being has never happened it's like
yo here's the thing like for ever I may
be one girl did that ass told me
straight up that she liked me right and
that girl was that weird girl I'll talk
about that's the type of women I've
never ever ever had that happen me yeah
so she did it right and then she left
and then my homie Jesse's like yo what
do you what are you doing dude she
wanted you to ask for her number I was
like is that this my response is that
what that was I was like hey literally
this was my reaction so we were talking
I told him was I thought that's what
that was just how bad I am right so
we're talking and in my head when that
pause came this is what was going on my
head she said until she said all right
I'll see you around
I'm okay and in my head right when she
left I was like damn I think she wanted
me like ask her for her number and then
immediately Jesse's like what are you
doing dude she wanted you to ask for a
number I'm like se this [ __ ] in like in
a cartoon or as she says stuff he's
talking in his head he goes I think she
wants me to touch and then when you look
and he gets out of it it's nighttime
that's what happened dude that like that
little passe felt like an eternity cuz
she were just sitting there staring each
other
do you still see her no well she's
married with kids now with a guy who
speaks how about you were deaf me how
long ago was this like a couple weeks
ago but it was like it was like a random
interaction oh you told me about this
yeah so this was a couple weeks ago bro
yeah dude do you know anything about
this person no she probably thinks
you're gay you hate her guts oh that too
I know that you like men and that's not
an insult that's just fact so did you
feel nervous while you were talking her
Wow there was like a long pause or like
no and I think you know when I'm around
people so like say if we what us three
went out and there was like a girl there
yeah or something like that I can talk
all day because I'm maybe hung people
maybe we need to like help him and like
bring he's a grown ass [ __ ] yeah oh dude
we do this together bro so like if we're
all there I'm more comfortable but if it
came to us at that I know but if we're
all comfortable and then if that happens
and it's easier for me because this has
happening with some of the girls that
I've ended up with where they were
friends of the group right they're all
groups so was easier like if we went and
started hanging out by ourselves there's
a lot easier those scenarios don't
happen a lot anymore I know and their
problem yeah and it's not the best
scenario it's not exactly but that's
that would make me more comfortable but
like I don't know I really I could not
tell you it's been my whole life since I
can so when that when the when it was
the eight [ __ ] minutes that happened
everything that sighs what were you
thinking like how did you feel I was
like I was like and I say a mixture of
nervous and like confused because in my
head like all these thoughts are going
through my head
am I supposed to ask her for a number no
she doesn't want that maybe she does I'm
[ __ ] nervous
holy [ __ ] were staring at each other
what am I supposed to do do I talk first
and then she was like okay I'll see you
later
that's what went on in my head and
that's what another scenario were like
my face and my skin you know like when
you get like embarrass them you get like
hot or something that [ __ ] happens me
around [ __ ] left house I [ __ ]
I think for you you just need to have
like a couple of go twos in those
situations like an easy one for you
especially in the gym context you should
always just be like hey we should live
together sometime yeah that has worked
once how many times have you used that
though once I guarantee you that but you
just have to kind of like it's like
fighting right it's like you have
pre-programmed combinations that you
know or your hitters like yeah you know
you'll land this every time you throw it
I feel like you need that when you're
you know talking with somebody just
always be like yo like we should we
should go I can't believe she was
staring at you and you didn't say
anything and then she just goes okay I
guess I'm gonna leave me this was not my
best moment was like you wanna go get
something to eat up this was I ain't mad
what you're doing after this I'm like
that those those statements right and
it's when people say like oh you gotta
say this you gotta say this
even our homie Pat everybody knows
Patrick like he says the same stuff and
I'm just like I understand I just for
some reason like I can't not because
you're you're already thank you know
you're already you're already committed
to a negative result of course yes and
that's exactly I'm always thinking the
worst that's gonna happen from it and
it's that's [ __ ] and it's weird
because that's kind of helped me in my
life in other situations not girls right
I always think about the negatives and
it's kind of train harder but it's also
it's also got me out of situations where
could have got in trouble or something
like that yeah but then I've done that
my whole life to worry that's also how I
deal with women and it's not that's not
the best way to think of everything
but yeah I mean it's and like meeting
women in small social circles now with
like your friends are there that that
starts to become few and far between as
you get older yeah you know it's not as
easy like in college like it would just
be like you and then you'd be kicking
with some boys and the girls would come
through and sometimes they'd bring
another homegirl then you would talk to
a girl and that would be it but what I
learned too was specifically after I
left I went to a UC are like why are he
had a girlfriend at the time so I didn't
really get a hit on anybody because you
know your boy faithful and [ __ ] hahaha
so I just super faithful and if you can
tell because I don't have of course you
wouldn't be able to talk
explode hey I'm trying to cheat you
would you start sweating on your clothes
I really let you so much yeah no way
you're gonna cheat what I found out was
that especially when I went to Community
College there isn't a lot of like
there's not a lot of program is not like
I'm not in a dorm so I can't believe
those situations so I just had to shoot
my shot to anybody like I like I was my
first year at CRC I said I want to try
to date a girl that's not [ __ ] Asian
this time so a prior to that I only had
one girlfriend I only like one girl in
high school and we ended up being
together that she tore my heart to a
million pieces shoutouts to you love you
very much or name can't say her name cuz
ii was a small town oh yeah that's right
yeah she's a very very sweet girl we
just didn't really mesh well and it was
like high school right yeah plus she's
up [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I'm kidding she trusts me so no my ex
is I want to hear these but I started
you know when I when I attended
Community College I was like okay if I
want to date somebody else outside of my
ethnicity
I just gotta shoot my shot see what
happens this first time I ever dated
white girl was my first class was in the
first set of class I remember which
class it was but it was a Polish girl
and I dated her for a quick second don't
want any NHS did it didn't really work
out but I asked her out and it happened
we had class we had small talk and it
worked out and that I was like oh this
just not that crazy like you just gotta
start asking people out like what's up
like a Patrick like watching Patrick
Reilly he's been on this podcast before
watching that guy talk with girls is
like wow like he it's it's it's cool to
see someone like really good at
something like someone like Mario Batali
you're watching him cook you're like wow
this is when you see guys who are really
smooth it's like damn I wish I could do
that man I don't have any but it's like
but but that guy could do that jason
chadman you're like damn I wish I could
do with Jason Chen nobody if I had them
vocal cords
but that watching him and what it is
it's it's just him just talking just
like knowing how to be a good
conversation and you know how to have
carrier a conversation I can yeah you
know how to do it
so just do that this podcast is brought
to you by skill share what is Skillshare
you ask it is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning Skillshare offers classes
designed for real life so you can learn
things that you want at your pace based
on your busy routine I know a bunch of
people out there want to make films for
fun or as a side hustle there's a lot of
classes that take the Skillshare offers
that I know a lot of you would enjoy
there's this course called video on a
budget and even a course for iPhone
filmmaking because everybody has a phone
and if you have a phone you can make
film do not worry about it go out there
and enjoy these courses I love them
explore your creativity and get to three
months of premium membership at skills
shared comm slash brain that's two whole
months of unlimited access that
thousands of classes for free get
started and joined today by heading to
Skillshare comm slash brain that's two
three months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes at Skillshare comm
slash brain when I was in high school
this I that was the thing it's like my
my natural instinct was to go with the
one girl that was like kind of enforcing
it right that started because I remember
there was a couple girls in high school
there's at the time I was talking to my
ex and these two other girls the other
two girls were very attractive and I
liked them and there was one girl that I
really liked but I didn't know if I
didn't know she was liking me or not and
like she would she was like purposely
like like walk out of her class and
stuff to meet up and talk with me but in
my head I just didn't process that as
like she's into me right there's a
window out of this building this really
I want you to lean on it
and there is times to were like because
like one little thing would happen and I
was like like I would text them and I'm
not like a person that would text text
text but I would text them they wouldn't
respond on my okay yeah I'm just they're
not good
that's like little [ __ ] like that would
be like oh I'm being annoying like I
need a backup quick I don't know what
happened it hurt me because ain't know
at the time when I had my girl it was
fun right like I don't want to like bash
on her and anything like that I also do
want to say go check out this full
Spotify he raps by Shia did love ya bash
your skull so that time that that
happened I was talking that and this
other girl and the other two girls my ex
was attractive too but the other girl
there's one girl out of all of them
right the girl that we used to meet up a
class and stuff and so and if I end up
start dating my ex and they [ __ ] like
broke my heart and this happened right
in the beginning of it
those other two girls literally went up
to my friend one of them went up to my
friend Thomas my best friend Thomas and
said hey you know I really thought I
which was into me we're really talking a
lot he's like I thought it's a little
weird that I all of a sudden he started
dating this girl and he tells me I'm
like wait what for real he's like guy
was like [ __ ] but the one that I was
super attracted to that one didn't go
that way she wants him you know your
friends at [ __ ] [ __ ] tomes who
never [ __ ] talk to me again how is he
gonna see her and flirt with me and talk
to me all the time and then go start
dating someone else and I was like hey
no no no I was so like that's proof that
Alex is pure at heart dude that's what
your problem is yeah you know your heart
is just as beautiful red and you need to
try some wrong your life baby
no man you need to do a little sinning
huh probably why you've had girlfriends
because they like that genuine side of
you so when you don't overthink
situations things just come easier right
case in point man there's these guys
they're called fang bros right these
guys
I've hear so many stories about these
lovely lovely two men there but they're
my heroes by the way I look up to these
guys right I feel like this is
disingenuous but continue no it's not I
know it's not what's not man they're the
best
so like you know like they're their
icons icons we just have the epitome of
Asian YouTube
I don't even know if they're Asian let
me just say it like how important they
are to the community uh-huh
continue when Kobe died didn't really
mean much if they died Wow that's I'm
saying that's how important they are
yeah that's how that's how that's how
dope they are but anyways I even for
those for these guys like I hear stories
about them all the time
through everybody tells me stories about
God knows why but they even those dweebs
have women that touch them yeah dude
right I mean they they I mean they go up
to women and they go have I must have to
swing in today they go up to women they
go do you know who these guys aren't you
too they have two million followers
you should watch their videos I'm this
guy and somehow it works yeah you had to
build a phone
I mean they shoot their shot and it
works about one out of like a hundred
times but there's one girl with low
self-esteem that always touches them
yeah it works yeah it's weird and I
don't know it's heroes heroes they're
[ __ ] key to the city just be [ __ ]
an icon bro I don't know I did it's so
weird and I've dealt with this my whole
life and I wish I didn't like it bums me
out that so you know what you have to do
right now you should have to tell
yourself no more of this [ __ ] no more
you know how long I've been telling
myself that but this is this is it hey I
have these random spurts of confidence
right like I'll be in my bed at night
I'm like you know [ __ ] like I talked to
myself all day and was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing dog let's do this
[ __ ] on your neighbor through the
curtains like shut the [ __ ] confident
to myself to do something and then I
like like I said 90% of the time won't
do it but sometimes I do do it I mean
like if the funny thing is is like I'm
not even telling you that you got to be
like Patrick you don't got to be mrs.
Bobby you just have to just do something
anything you could even be like when in
that moment where she looked at you you
could have just been like
hi said Eddie yeah honestly just not
just you tell everybody no matter who
the context is just always say hey come
work out with me yeah I guess that's
what it is really what it comes down to
it at the end of days like have a plan I
don't want to be weird or creepy or have
the girls feel uncomfortable and I just
feel like no matter what I do I don't
even think his own and also I just feel
like no matter what I do if they're not
interested in me and I'm trying to it
I've become creepy and weird that's not
that's not a kid to you though because
yeah it's not you dude like it's like
for example we all know creepy dudes
this this goes this goes for anything
depending on if the person finds you
attractive or not is the only factor
that differentiates somebody from being
creepy or not that's it that's it that's
it see you that's actually very true
I've seen my personal [ __ ] home girls
go on rants talking about these creepy
[ __ ] guys right but they tell the
story about the guy that they're dating
and they're doing the same thing that
creepy guys are doing the only
difference is is that guy was
good-looking yeah that's it you know you
know the things like to say to Tiffany
my fiance and I've been with her for 10
years I take the things I used to say to
her when we were dating were all very
unforgivable things like what I used to
say very perverted things to her like
what and she was like into it I want to
hear what a sample but uh but if you
know who Tiffany she's a very sue and I
was surprised I didn't just walk that
let me spit in your [ __ ] hole I know
I'm very close and it worked some but it
was but we were like we're like juniors
in high school right start with things
like yo like I would say you've been
saying this like makes me fuels day now
I'd be like yo like what kind of like
what color is your thong right now and I
would like I would be a I'd be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like I would be a pervert and
like and it worked because she liked you
and I'd be like y'all like I wonder if
like I'm gonna [ __ ] I would say it's
up in the center quadrant front every I
was a [ __ ] like that but see and sing
that out loud makes me sweat
because I just got all respect for dick
but but like this is current dick that
would only work if we were and we had a
relationship pretty like we were talking
but it was yeah and that's just a I mean
just a prep don't don't say that
whoever's little say exactly what other
girl only preface is like what what
happens when you have a certain vibe in
a feel with somebody right so for
example when Mary all night I told the
story how Muriel and I started dating
she and I were already flirting for four
you know back and forth a lot and then
when we went on this thing which I
thought was a date but it wasn't a date
she gives me this really awkward hug and
I was like hey cool by the way I'm not
your friend
we're dating so we're not friends yeah
and I said it's true if I said that some
random girl she would call the cops on
me sound like a rapist yeah you know the
way he said it was like this
hey we're dating yeah he's like I was
holding her by the neck so that mean
there's context to that stuff right I
mean obviously with if there's a girl
that's flirting you guys are talking
back and forth consistently and then you
just up and bounce and you starts dating
some other girl I probably mad too if I
was a girl I'd be like yeah what the
[ __ ] I was jacking off to your [ __ ]
face all night I know I think comes down
to it or I always growing up I never
felt like I was attractive I was always
a little chunkier and stuff like that so
it just it got worse it got what that
feels like I got worse and worse as I
got older because it like wasn't
changing you know like nothing was
changing so it got worse and worse and
worse and worse and worse but you didn't
get a confidence boost when you had
girlfriends though yeah like you know
and it's weird it's even to this day you
know even all my close friends are like
when we have this conversation because
all my friends know me and they all know
I've always been like this they always
say Lucas guys lineup have you ever seen
his girls and yeah a lot of my
girlfriends are very attractive and I
know this and stuff but I still I don't
know why that that does not give me any
like it once that relationship ends or
something like that I was like see see
you get what I'm saying like not you for
but see that's what I'm saying that's
like you
have a self-fulfilling prophecy you're
just waiting for something bad to happen
when it happens and I need to get and I
know that and that's like the worst
thing about me and I know I want to have
these conversations with myself like I'm
at home and stuff that's what I tell
myself oh my I got to stop being so
negative about everything Vinnie and
nega and then like [ __ ] with my last
relationship right like I would say
everything with every relationship I
probably grow better like you know when
I was first in my first relationship I
was very jealous because I always felt
like oh I'm not good enough what she can
go get this better looking guy why was I
yeah like that too and you know that was
with every relationship but it got
better and better over time you know cuz
I'm like all right you know I'm tripping
on a little bit whatever let that type
of stuff and then so like even with this
last one I was trying my hardest not to
be like that but what all this [ __ ] that
went on with this last one I like it
[ __ ] it up like a lot because I'm like
your last ex-girlfriend those kind of
hard to say because you can't base it on
she was a [ __ ] psychopath yeah now
the story happened that was insane yeah
that one was crazy and that was very
that what I would say is my first like
very toxic relationship that was
actually like [ __ ] with me because
during the time that I was with her she
made me feel like I was I was actually
like the fucked-up one well she
manipulated and then afterwards when she
wanted to get back together with me it
was her apologizing saying oh you were
right for all this you were right you
were right to feel this way all this
stuff but I'm like yeah it already
[ __ ] me up so much right because I
invested all this time and all this
energy into all this [ __ ] but also to
like I feel like just because I know the
story a bit yeah just from a background
perspective you also just you were a
little bit of a pushover
oh yeah just because like just to
preface this right she lived with her
ex-boyfriend
yeah and you were like that's normal
this was the thing when that happened I
wasn't okay with it but the person she
got mad at me and I was never okay with
it but I was such a pushover in that
relationship that I just let it happen
yeah I didn't I didn't you're in an
abusive relationship is what you really
sure and it was like you know and I
remember during the time I remember
because going into that the whole thing
the whole [ __ ] was
hold English [ __ ] but I remember going
into my car like a now I'm older I can't
be always like negative I can't be like
oh this person wants leave me all the
type of [ __ ] but that really ship did
not help that [ __ ] at all because during
it it was like you know I don't know if
the [ __ ] is going on right now
but I was so stuck into it for summer
because I really at the time I thought I
love the girl right so it was like hard
for me to get away from me and then when
she would do [ __ ] like that like when
she moved in with her ex-boyfriend again
it was I had an issue with it but I
don't know she had a way to make me
still stay I think that like oh you're
being I was overreacting and like some
of the times like I would this like okay
cool in my head I would be like no I
know I'm not tripping but you know I had
strong feelings for the girl so I'm like
I'm just gonna stay what did you like
about her originally I think it was like
we were into similar stuff that I
thought right as we got deeper into the
relationship I figured out that okay a
lot of the stuff were not into the lot
of the same things right but I don't
know obviously she was attractive I
thought she was attractive I found her
attractive I thought she was super nice
she was fun like we we like to do a lot
of the same stuff so it was fun like
when we were hanging out and she was a
friend of our group so we all had fun
together I used to be myself like this
like with us talking [ __ ] and stuff
that's how I was around her and it was
normal that's how it was so when like
that [ __ ] started happening it started
going to different levels like it was a
lot easier for me to get into it but I
think that was it I think I I don't know
if I was super interesting being around
her and her she approached you it was
her in the beginning you know obviously
she was attractive and you know I as a
guy you know it was think about like oh
she's a hot girl like you know what [ __ ]
right that's like the normal thing that
goes in your head I never in [ __ ] my
life's time thought that it would
actually turn into what it turned into
but no she had started it originally
because coming back to me having zero
idea it would be her messaging me all
day every day all day every day all day
every day and during that time I was
happening even in my head I'm like oh
she's just a nice person that's why
she's talking me all the time
and one of my one of my best friends
Alfonso used to tell me like dog she's
into you like she wants you I'm like no
she has a boyfriend like she's just
super nice she just talks to me a lot
and it was always that over and over
again he would be telling Mack dude no
no one talks to a person this much
especially of the other sex like this
much where you guys are staying up to
like [ __ ] 1 o'clock in the morning
and she's messaging you and in my head I
still think he ignored no she's just
nice right and I had to come to a point
where she kind of made the first move on
me and I was like okay yeah so this is
something this isn't like we're just
homies right anymore so yeah she she
started it she started it what was her
exact words none she just she like when
she dropped me off over he's my ass no
we went and hung out we went in hung out
once that's what it takes for this due
to pull the trigger I know and then he's
like I don't think she likes me I'm I
hate her ass for like three hours I
still don't think she's into me
um what's it called so like I went we
went hung out whatever and when she had
drove me and when she dropped me off at
home when I went in for a hug she like
went in to give me a kiss and then I
asked on my or he just did you try to
kiss me because I'm gonna [ __ ] no but
here let me let me defend myself let me
defend myself about a second bro I don't
give a [ __ ] you receive the kiss and
then you went are you okay she didn't
kiss me but she was like well I went in
for the hug she was coming in like as
she was gonna kiss me so I stopped on my
oh are you trying to kiss me and she
just stopped and look at me and in my
head she's with somebody still you know
oh she had a boyfriend
yes so that's why I was kind of like oh
you try to kiss me and then it was like
she asked me what do you want to kiss me
and I'm like I mean if you want to I
mean yeah if you want a kiss that's fine
right I feel like most people would have
just like not even thought about how she
has a boyfriend and just boom I okay
you're [ __ ] funny man that shows how
pure this fool is though I know but he
still spoke about it like it was a
business transaction are you trying to
kiss me do you wanna kiss me yeah
that's gonna be 100 bucks but this guy's
the king of consent do like I like your
consent man I was right in I am and I
tried I tried I tried to be right so
when that happened like I remember going
home and when I travel I go home I'm
like oh that relationship [ __ ] right
that that grows that goes there goes
that friendship whatever right because
that was [ __ ] awkward as [ __ ]
right like so I got home next day it was
fun like we went and hung out play so
you guys didn't kiss no we didn't kiss
Alex what no so we didn't kiss no
because she has a boyfriend that's right
yeah no principles so we like that I
wouldn't have I would not have kissed
either yeah and then suppose dudes would
have so the next day kind of trap almost
kind of almost kind of like how you guys
told me just right now like you need to
sin a little bit more right or whatever
like this that was it what he said I
said I'm like yeah but that wasn't that
wasn't my agreement but she asked me to
hang out the next day so we do and it
was around like Christmastime or
whatever like that and so we hang out
whatever and we go to a restaurant there
was like a gift being made we go to a
restaurant and we sit down and I sit
across from her right and at this point
she says why don't you come and sit next
to me so hard in my head on my okay so
she wants obviously this is not our
friendship dinner anymore right this is
going to something else so we go and
then like it turns as I put my arm
around her and then she wants a kiss so
then we kiss right so like I remember
going after that like I felt guilty
because I'm like yo this girl has a girl
this girl has a guy and I was like you
know I don't I don't like to do [ __ ]
like this because I think about like how
you would feel if you yeah exactly it's
almost cheating or netic and which I'm
sure she [ __ ] did but you know it's
like that's how I think and but at the
time like she was very attractive and I
was kind of just like oh [ __ ] this is
happening this is cool right I would
have never expected and she was she was
precedent so yeah and so you know it
went whatever went down like that and
then so like the whole thing leading up
to it was I was kind of being don't get
me wrong this whole
I was dumb for staying and I know that
now obviously during the time my some of
my closest friends who cared about me
trying to get me onto the relationship
but I was so stuck in it it was done for
me to be in there but though the
beginning of it was that I was I was
kind of being she was kind of leaning me
on and since that she kept telling me
she was gonna break up with her guy and
because of how I am I just believed her
so I would stay around and it was to the
point where I'm like waiting waiting and
waiting and waiting and like it's just
like all this [ __ ] and it was about like
two months of it and then I remember
finally like Valentine's Day came around
and I was kind of excited my oh look I'm
gonna have a [ __ ] Valentine's this
year so I think we yeah I think we went
out to dinner whatever like that and
then that same day like they broke up
right and I'm just like oh [ __ ] and then
so I was like cool like finally they
broke up now we can have our thing right
because we've already been planning this
for two [ __ ] months anyways and she
said that she wanted to be with me and
when they broke up we can be together
but then I switched to when they broke
up oh I don't I can't do this can't be
in a relationship I can't do this I
didn't realize how much this was gonna
affect me I can't be in a relationship
with you and I was just like oh [ __ ] so
that hit me hard because I'm like for
two months I stood around because I'm
buying into this thing that like when
this is done I'm gonna be able to be
with you right and we're gonna be able
to be a thing so already throughout this
time right I had a DM her wasn't allowed
to text her because she didn't want her
guy seeing her texting me and all that
type of [ __ ] right so then after that
they broke up it was like basically like
a two-month period where we didn't talk
and I was so like heartbroken by it
because I had invested all my time into
it thinking that like oh when they break
up we're gonna be together so when that
happened I was [ __ ] up about it right
I didn't want to talk to anybody anyways
my friends are trying to get me to talk
to other people it just wasn't into it
and there was a couple of times where I
could have went out on dates and I
purposely made up reasons to cancel them
because I didn't want to go because I
didn't want to car broke down and you
would have picked up by now huh
like no my car broke down they offered
to pick me up on my na na and meet you
there
so like later on later on this [ __ ] ends
up happening right where we're dating a
lot of [ __ ] happens and stuff and I'll
talk a lot about I don't want to say
certain things yeah yeah
but yeah so we we end up start dating
again and it comes to a point where
there's a I mean already just off the
bat it was such a volatile thing like
there's nothing ever that's gonna come
good of that oh no like just just from
that personality set and how she started
the the quote-unquote relationship there
was nothing great about that yeah and I
know this and I remember she even told
me this to she was like I don't want you
thinking you know I know I cheated oh my
god but that's not who I am and me being
dumb believe it I believed it right but
I should know like no that's not that's
who she is if she's willing to do that
for a person that she's been in a
relationship with whatever how long they
were she's probably gonna do that to me
right because I'm just some guys matter
right [ __ ] and so um so it comes to a
point where she has an operative move
right
so she moves in with her ex-boyfriend
again and well you guys were dating at
this time yeah so it was weird I we well
I would say we are officially start yes
we were official I believe before she
moved out and she moved back into her
exposome everyone in your circle her
circle knew that you know together so
that was the thing because she wanted to
be respectful to her ex and they didn't
want to show like she just jumped right
into a relationship we had to purposely
keep this a secret
right and that was I would say that's
what [ __ ] me up the most cuz I was the
hardest because like people like I would
be around people and people would see
her and she's attractive and I have
people coming up to me saying damn you
see her man I [ __ ] the SH out of her
my hand what you [ __ ] this [ __ ] ever I'm
hearing all different ways that people
would [ __ ] my girlfriend and all its
stuff like this right but I can't say
anything because I'm not allowed I'm not
supposed to be telling people this [ __ ]
right so like every day I had to deal
with the [ __ ] when we were out at the at
the gym and it's just like I used to
[ __ ] eat me alive and then she would
ask me why are you mad or like it would
come up I get obviously my attitude
change right I'm not gonna be a [ __ ]
happy right when I hear this [ __ ] and
she would ask me like oh why are you
bothered and I would tell her she's like
why does that bother you why does that
even bother you I'm like she's like I'm
with you so why does that bother you I
really I'm like oh my gosh stop dating
why does that bother you I'm with you
and another guy yeah and we can't tell
anybody about it yes what's the problem
so I used to I used to like eat me alive
because on my [ __ ] like obviously I
believe you stuck around that like trust
me I am this I'm very stupid but it's
also like where your head space was at
the time yeah right and you did talk
about how you felt like you were like
even beyond that too because you have
such low self-esteem every time you're
with somebody you still can't believe
that you're with this person that's what
it was no it was a hundred percent that
and because I knew of this person for a
while and I always thought she I was
always attracted to her right I never
thought in my whole entire life that
this situation would be happening and
that stuff becomes problematic because
like what happens is you also put this
person on a pedestal so every time they
do something wrong you think like well
when am I gonna find this another person
like this again yeah and then you excuse
negative behaviors constantly because
you feel like you were undeserving of
their affection yeah so then that's
problematic so no matter what you do
from a from a relationship on here you
have to feel like you're on equal
grounds that's how it is with
friendships too if you if not even just
regular friendships if you have a friend
right and you feel like that friend is
beneath you no matter what they say
let's say like um like I think Nick is
[ __ ] beneath me right which is great
that and this is how he feels right I'm
good with it so we're at we're having a
regular conversation is that I think you
and I are equals right we're all having
a group conversation and this isn't a
friendship scenario we're talking about
let's say I don't know what to do with
the pile of money and how we should
invest it right you you you say
something right let's say you don't even
know about money but because I respect
you know I think you're equals I'll sit
here and listen to what you have to say
you'll be like yeah I think we should do
should take that money and put it into
this this and that and those gain
interested you'll get money I'm like
cool Nick comes up and Nick will go like
crypto and it goes you know what I think
you should invest my but you shut the
[ __ ] up all right and you could say the
same thing you're saying David this
happened yesterday yeah and by the way
actually happened at lunch yesterday
that's the best thing about seeing
people as equals right yeah is like it
causes a better relationship a lot of
the times people jump into bed with
certain people even in relationships and
friendships and they're not equals and
they don't even know it yeah and it
causes this weird dynamic right and in
your case that's what it is
yeah and that was the thing and then too
so like it was things like that that
would bother me and it would and then
like all the sudden you know I was
jealous now I was the jealous person and
so like I would go home and be like [ __ ]
I'm being jealous and I told myself I
didn't want to be this way but I knew I
was being jealous right I knew I was
being jealous because because of all the
[ __ ] that was happening obviously I was
jealous of it right because all these
people are saying [ __ ] I can't say
anything right and it just got it got to
that point to where like so she moved
back in with her ex mm-hmm I wasn't
happy about it and but that turned into
a fight and I remember thinking to
myself like after that fight I was like
I feel like I should be able to be mad
about this but she's telling me I'm not
so like I started telling myself like
maybe I'm not allowed to be mad about
this maybe I am being jealous again and
being overreacting so cuz that's what it
was I was jealous I was jealous for her
it sounds like that's what she always
goes to yeah I was too jealous for her
and it's not I started believing that I
was like [ __ ] I know so what was the
last straw for you that and I what made
you so this is what happened so um a lot
of the stuff that she did was with her
ex now right because she lived there and
it was little things like posting food
of plates right there's two places she's
cooking food I know who the other plates
for right and I'm over here eating by
myself I'm going to restaurants eating
by myself and then I go on Instagram and
is the saddest and funniest thing I've
ever heard and then then I see that
she's cooking dinner or they're at
restaurants and I know who the other
person there is with her right
so you still I used to bother me a lot
cuz I'm used to but I [ __ ] man and I
remember bringing it up to her once
she's like why does that bother you I'm
like because you're my girlfriend and
I'm eating alone but you're eating with
your ex he gets to eat with you I don't
like what I don't get it
so what would she say when you would
tell her that but she's like you know
you this was that I don't even remember
yes basically that so basically that
like oh but I'm your girlfriend but at
the time did he know that you guys were
now still not well that was the thing so
even during this time I still get in
texture yo people to not I have to DM
her only because I was think cause as
she moved back in there she wasn't
paying rent he was letting her lived
there you're the side chick I know and I
know that nowadays right but yeah so I
couldn't text her because she didn't
want him to see her texting me all the
time and then possibly kick her out and
she had nowhere to go
bro people are so mean but why are you
guys
why are you certain for her well-being
you know I don't know and I would have
these little moments where I'd be like I
don't give a [ __ ] he's an ICU in charge
you I remember I used to ask that is he
in charge of you does he run your [ __ ]
whatever like that
and he used to lead into fights but
basically what happened so she broke up
with me and the reasoning why was
because she was going out to dinner with
one of her friends and I remember this
day because I was at work and I text her
my oh that sounds cool and I asked her
because that girl also has a guy and he
was going so I asked him like oh is your
ex going with you and she completely
blew it off she just went she kept going
on with it because every time she would
go out now when we're not together I was
like oh is your ex going with you and
how often were you at this time how
often were you hanging out with her just
you and her we would try so when I
started what was the ratio with where
she would hang I would see her two maybe
three times a week for about two of
those times for about five hours and one
of the times for about like towards the
middle of the day and she would spend
the night whatever that and then go back
to [ __ ] everybody who's listening to
this story is just like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with Alice and then so yeah
basically that what it was so I used
every time she used to go do [ __ ] right
my first reaction is oh are you going
with your ex because secretly in my mind
I thought oh there's their [ __ ]
they're together right I'm being played
secretly in my mind but I didn't want to
believe that because I did believe that
she had like she really was like with me
right I don't know why
and so finally it came to that and I
asked her again I asked her like three
times I'm like are you as your ex going
with you like you're like completely
pointless conversation of this question
and that's what led into her breaking up
with me saying that she couldn't handle
this anymore I'm Way too jealous
way too jealous of you're so crazy done
yeah and then so she broke up with me
obviously I [ __ ] me up right because
we're already together for a decent
amount of time and what we weren't
together for a long time but the whole
situation went on for a long time us
being official wasn't that long it was
maybe about four five no she slipped it
out on you and after she flipped it on
you you felt bad oh yeah so when she
broke up with me I was torn up by it
right at the end of the day man like
before you even try to get another
relationship you need you need like your
own personal self esteem below I know
it's this right here is like a vicious
cycle every time that you get with
somebody and you feel like you don't
deserve them no matter what they do
they're gonna be able to run you over
[ __ ] it constantly and that's the hard
part it's like yeah you can get with
somebody unless by chance you find
another saint like find the saint that
will never ever do that to you most
people aren't like that because when
people could sense weakness even it was
somebody that you loved they take
advantage of it yeah and I built up a
little bit of strength I'd say out of
all this because I'd say for like 3-4
months I was torn up by it right and it
kind of knows cuz I it was around the
same time when we started training
together yeah he would tell me these
stories and I'd be like why ya know like
we had already been training but like
this was after you had left and we were
doing one-on-one yeah so I started
telling him more about what was going on
with my situation and I was I was pretty
messed up by it I was really sad I was
depressed right like go home cry all
that type of [ __ ] right like I was
really messed up about it and then like
over time like there was moments where I
went through a lot of [ __ ] at the time
like number one I was on [ __ ] tests
right so my test levels were up right so
maybe my emotional state was gonna be
worse anyways but then one of my
longtime clients or one of my first
clients passed away in January so this
all was happening right after another
right but before that we had broke up
there was about two months or she did
we didn't talk and I was really
devastated by it then my client passed
away right before that she had kind of
barely started talking to me again like
here and there like sending these little
things and it was weird I remember
feeling weird about it like I was kind
of excited but I was like [ __ ] I was so
worried about if I get back together
with this girl my friends are gonna
[ __ ] either stop talking to me or
they're gonna start doing some cuz they
[ __ ] hate this girl so you knew that
like you had the potential of falling
back you know I did I did and there was
I mean there was an opportunity and I
just felt weird and like [ __ ] happened
with my client he passed away all that
type of stuff so but it came to a point
where like [ __ ] kept happening to where
I started kind of turning into like sad
to like yell [ __ ] this right [ __ ] this
girl and I got to that point to where
around like a March time around whenever
this happened in a March time I forget
what year I think was last year
basically it was that she wanted to get
back together with me and I was I was
proud of myself in the sense because I
literally straight-up told her I don't
want to be with you I don't want to be
around you I don't want to see you and I
don't want to talk to you I think it's
best for us if we don't see each other
talk to each other or anything like I
don't I just don't want to do it anymore
and then that's when all the [ __ ] you
know I'm so sorry I ruined us I should
have this you you had all the you were
you had all the right to be jealous you
got all this type of stuff but I
remember telling myself I remember
reading it and obviously it was I was so
my had like I'll [ __ ] like she feels bad
remember I tell myself like no [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I don't want that so crazy how were
your breakouts I don't want to deal with
this [ __ ] no more and a big thing that
helped me out was my friends being so
Stern on me like yo this girl is not
good for you she used you and all this
type of [ __ ] right so eventually I was
able to [ __ ] tell her like look I
don't wanna we're done like I don't want
you anymore all these other times i sat
here and waited around for you and I was
you know sad and stuff and then you
would come back when you wanted me or
what I wanted whatever you wanted for me
and I was there to do it this time it's
not the same no more like I don't want
to do it no more but but you see like
the change of like her response when you
set that boundary yeah I'm you were like
straight up with her yeah you're honest
with her people are interesting too
because you didn't have to do all
I'm a very spiteful human being so I can
somebody somebody who are you trying to
make sure that they hurt ten times more
yeah so like for me like in that
situation she could be I'm so sorry Baba
blah I would have just been like okay
and they text you again and then you
just leave it alone leave it alone and I
felt bad about this in like yeah we had
this conversation not too long ago when
I finally told you about this whole
situation right yes
I still felt weird to like not tell
people yeah like I was still like
looking up like oh I don't want to say
this I don't I didn't tell people why
but then then it kind of clicked on my
head like you know I shouldn't have to
hide the [ __ ] no more like I don't give
a [ __ ] right you know I'm not gonna go
and blast the person's name everywhere
and [ __ ] but I shouldn't have to hide
this [ __ ] no more and that was the thing
I was hiding it from a lot of people I
was hiding it people from people that
were really close to me which is
starting to make me feel different ways
about the people that were close to me
you know like all the sudden I'm like
not liking people that are close to me
but it was because due to all the
[ __ ] stress that was happening to me
little things were like [ __ ] pissing
me off and you know making my attitude
change towards people I mean you I mean
like I said like you know empathy is a
great thing to have but at times like
you kind of give too much you don't have
anything left for yourself yeah so like
especially like you're having empathy
for somebody who doesn't really deserve
it
everybody is [ __ ] up for a reason so
that's where my empathy goes as far out
- right so when somebody does something
wrong to me after after is said and done
after I slashed their tires at home and
I'm reading my Bible and you know I'm
praying hymns usual you know it's been
you know
the beads and everything I start to
realize like the end of my empathy comes
I'm like this person is [ __ ] up and
did this fucked-up thing to me because
something happened them and I don't know
what it is but that's really as far as
it goes right yeah because I can only
try to empathize so I don't have hate in
my heart but that doesn't mean that you
get an excuse for your behavior
yeah I forgive people not for them I do
it for myself so you let it go so I
can't even [ __ ] on and that's what
people have to get to forgiveness for me
isn't so I can make that person sleep
well at night I don't say hey you're
forgiven because I want you to feel good
about yourself
I say you're forgiven so I can move the
[ __ ] on so I don't have to [ __ ] worry
about you I don't have to sit here with
this hate in my heart because that's the
part that [ __ ] me up because then you
get to take a piece of me that I never
allowed you to have yeah so when you had
like this type of like anger that's
where that's where empathy and that's
how I use my empathy anyways because
what happens when you start worrying
about other people especially when they
don't deserve it if they just take
pieces away from you all the time every
time you see something that reminds you
of them you get [ __ ] angry [ __ ] up
your whole day so they get to take that
from you why did they keep on getting to
taketake can take even after they're out
of your life yes it's not [ __ ] fair
yeah not that's what was going on and
even after like when I told her I didn't
want to be with her I was killed I was
still more on the side of like you look
look I I still care about her right I
still care about her well-being I just
don't want to see her I don't want to
like damn not and I would even have that
yeah and I felt that way until stuff
started coming out about I've started
finding about lies that she told me
about [ __ ] people when she was
telling me she didn't and it was huge
fights telling these lies about specific
things and I started hearing these
things and I'm like yo I know a [ __ ]
this girl like no I don't care about you
no more obviously I don't wish any harm
or ill-will and so I always like if she
gets coronavirus it's maybe buddy yeah I
wouldn't care you know really and it
just I don't ever really hate people
that much but I would say for this
person like I have a little bit of hate
in my heart but also I'm like you know
what I feel like I'm a little better now
no matter what I'm always gonna be
nervous to talk to girls I could try to
fix that but that [ __ ] I feel like
whenever I'm in my next relationship
we'll see
might've it might have [ __ ] me up I'm
nervous about that right I don't think
it should [ __ ] you up because like once
again in this situation though she is a
[ __ ] the person in your case you have to
take that personal responsibility of
saying that you actually didn't set any
boundaries for yourself you let this
person take you over because you know
you felt that you didn't deserve them so
you allowed yourself to be punked by
this girl and there was a lot of huge
signs for you it's not like that what it
was like looking like hey this is what
I'm gonna do with my ex-boyfriend
alright we're gonna have dinners
together and I'm a post that picture you
get to see it ah ha then I'm gonna deny
it I bet she was surprised she was like
wow I can't believe this is going on
well there was one to write this this
was the war this was a big one - I
remember this cuz she was like oh I'm
gonna go out to dinner and uh all these
people are coming she told me that right
because this was already at the time she
was living with her ex so I think she
told me that immediately because she
probably knew I was gonna ask her like
oh is your ex going right so she told me
there's like all these she listed off
all these people that were going to this
dinner right it was like some big dinner
and then she even said and my ex is
coming too because you know he's friends
with these people - alright cool that's
cool so I ended up still following one
of the people that were in that group
right and I I literally was so fun with
it when she told me I'm like hey I was
like it was the one day this is what
hurt me the most right because I was
like hey look I'm okay with it she
straight up told me like straight up and
I was like oh cool again this is cool
she told me I don't have to worry about
it right she's gonna go do this I know
they're all friends and stuff like that
I'm scrolling through my Instagram at
home and then that person that I follow
those in the group posted a picture said
date night with my favorite couple hey
man that girl and her and her ex so I
screenshot it right I got piss like I
was so [ __ ] hot dude and I saw it my
skin was red I remember standing up in
my room like what the [ __ ] like I was so
heated I screenshot it and I sent to
turn I was like have fun on your date
and then she wrote back stop being
jealous and you're like you're right
like oh hi I asked them I told them not
to post anything like that they all know
that were not together I don't know why
they would say that and she's like I
we're going home
I'm going home we were supposed to go do
all this stuff but I'm going home but I
also she got mad and retaliate I'm going
home I told them I don't want to go do
anything else so I'm going home tonight
his face
I remember feeling that was one of the
[ __ ] days huh [ __ ] see cuz I felt
good I was like oh look she told me this
am i oh cool I'm this is not normal for
me normally I would still be bothered
I'm not and then that same [ __ ] night
I was like what in the [ __ ] I was so
heated with that [ __ ] in that you should
probably would have stopped talked to
her at that point yeah no but here's a
relationship only lasted like 2 more
weeks after that but the prices are
right sides of having this relationship
is like chances are you're not gonna get
[ __ ] that's gonna be watching melody or
as bad hopefully not because now you
know now you now you know that like
you've been there yeah you've understood
the signs of pretty much abuse yeah
being fully taken I mean sure she'll be
problematic in her other relationships
and everything else that she does yeah
that's just how she is nobody's really
going to correct her because she
probably doesn't really have any that
many close friends and if they she does
have quote/unquote close friends from
her behavior because I don't really know
her like that cuz I met her before
mm-hmm and when I met her everybody
knows I told him I didn't have a good
feeling about her robbed the jump night
what was it just having conversations
and I'm like no something I don't like
about this person and I just kind of you
know move on from it but you you see me
like that with people like if people I
don't like it like you could tell yeah
my skin and I can't control it you
remind me of one of my buddies that does
the same thing to tell me how often are
we right though know like 10 for 10 bro
like out of all the times where all my
others do sketch you're always right
same with a homie yeah and is that is
and it doesn't happen to a lot of people
but when it when the spidey sense is
tingling like this before no reason and
it's an it's reminiscent of that person
right inside some about this person is
off and I feel like I've been [ __ ]
over by somebody like this yeah and it's
usually I don't know what it is I can't
put it into words but it's because I've
been through it and I'm seeing it again
yeah so I just go oh something's off
about here it's like when the [ __ ]
and
Lopez in the [ __ ] [ __ ] May here at
leaf run all right though exactly yeah
when I met this person I was like
they're nice but something's off and I
kind of just disses myself after that
yeah and that's the thing it's like
super nice right and you know being me I
was like oh she's super nice like it was
cool and then now I know she and I even
like this is just recent too and you
know it's still I hate that this [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me for so long because even
still to this but how can I'm not though
dude I know but it's still like having
some self-respect Alice yeah even
recently I was like I was still catching
myself like is I'm not scared to tell
the story anymore right like I'll tell
people what [ __ ] happen and but I
would still be like I would be like this
you know but really though like I
understand I was jealous I'll give her
that I was jealous but then even like a
couple weeks I'm like what I'm saying
that she's still play with yourself yeah
I'm like why why am I still saying like
I'm trying to give her something like oh
I was jealous though so she did have a
reason to do this but at the end of the
day I'm like I think I'm saying that
because I don't want to be like because
I know when you tell story everybody
said oh well I want to hear their side
of the story right yeah so I say that
because I know I was jealous so I want
I'm trying to get it my point across
like look I know I'm telling the truth
and I know that this person is lying
about this because I've already heard
from someone else that she ended up
dating that just the world so small that
that person is kind of close to me in a
sense I don't know that person but the
relationship is closed to me that she is
still she's lying about everything right
so it's like that's why I say the I that
feel like I still say that wall I know I
was jealous because I want to let
everybody know that I am telling the
truth
well it's pretty wrong let's bring her
on that shave it they're gonna do work
his magic and but he's probably gonna
change her life she'll lie I mean change
people's I hear they heard that [ __ ]
that she was lying about to to this
person what was the most like egregious
lie um I know after when you're trying
to make me say but I'm not gonna know
I'm not gonna know what it's okay
but nothing like even scandalous yeah
one of the ones was like she told this
person the person finally confronted her
about me because she had supposedly told
this person the guy that she
the new she told this person that she
didn't have any relationship outside of
her ex right there was nothing well
small he finds out that there was a
relationship and it was with me so he
confronts her about it this is what I
hear from this person right so if this
is true I'm not sure this is what I was
just told and I'm never going to talk to
her to get her side of the story because
I could give a [ __ ] what she says that
she told him okay yes we dated it was
small we broke up in the beginning of
September so I tell the guy I'm like oh
in September that's weird and he's like
why I'm like because at the end of
September I took her to Arizona to visit
all of my family so that was weird that
we stopped we broke up in the beginning
summer but I still brought her out to
Arizona to meet everybody right and I
told him like no we broke up in November
that's when we broke up cuz I remember
because I was excited like oh look I
might be able to bring my girlfriend
back home for Thanksgiving but we broke
up in November so I'm like oh that
[ __ ] sucks is there goes that plan
right and then that was the last time I
talked to her supposedly was in [ __ ]
September I'm like that's weird because
when my client died she was talking me
all the time I mean she went to my house
and she made me some cool little thing
with my clients like picture in it she
left it on my door right in my car door
I'm like that's that doesn't seem like I
mean that's January so September and I
was like and I have text messages and
his the other person that was there
started reading the text messages off to
the person with the date I'm like this
is March dog this isn't September so I
already know that she's lying about the
situation and I know she's probably
lying about it to a [ __ ] ton of people
but I think I'm getting to that point
where I'm kind of like I don't give a
[ __ ] she's still with the other guy I
don't I what I don't know um cuz if she
is dude she's a wizard I just know what
she does but you gotta give her credit
like does her [ __ ] have an extra set of
lips
I guess latches on to like your dick
like what the [ __ ] is it that she has
that has a spell over people I don't
know it's good I think it's because
she's attractive and she's super nice I
think that's what it is cuz when you
don't know her like deeply know her
she's super nice and that's very
but manipulative people will do what
they do yeah and I and they know how I
don't want to say this like a lot of I
don't say they're predatory but a lot of
them kind of are like they know they
know who they could work with who they
could kind of like a lot of people
getting with duped by people who are
nice because and it's hard for people to
understand this concept that nice
doesn't mean you're a good person
yeah right it just doesn't true some
people are just very good with their
mouth they know how to say say the right
things it doesn't mean that they're a
good [ __ ] human being there are
people now that I said I'm still friends
with till this day like even Muriel
doesn't get it right like I have a guy
uh home me out in Sacramento she met
this guy she doesn't like him right
she's like oh he's loud he's calm
obnoxious I was like yeah but he's a
really good guy right and she goes like
how like he curses so much so do I say
[ __ ] I was like the difference is is
that he's a good person I was like good
people are hard to come by
likeable people are a dime a dozen yeah
there's a lot of likeable [ __ ] human
beings they know how to say the right
things they know how to make you feel
special in a conversation but I always
say to like that guy
if tomorrow if tomorrow I said yo man uh
I need a place to stay he'd be like come
over to my spot here's my keys stay here
as long as you want that's a good
[ __ ] dude yeah he's that type of
human being and so she doesn't
understand sometimes why keep certain
people from my past I was like because
on the exterior they're very rough it's
not the most likable human being but
he's a good [ __ ] worse like Harvey
Weinstein likeable person I'm sure I've
been proud of myself in the sense of the
way I've gotten over it too now cuz I
when I was first like rethinking about
like the timeline like for some reason I
just always thought it was like years
ago but it was like a way no a year ago
I think it was like two years ago now
but it still comes it's still very fresh
it was fresh and bad this that's why I
also get mad I'm like yo this [ __ ] was a
long time ago and I still think about it
to this day you know I just popped in my
head just to just to go back to how like
how this guy's such a good person I'm
not really so well now when I was in um
in college I made I had a still had a
few bad habits of being very aggressive
and angry yeah
didn't want to be in this school at all
so I had a problem with a lot of people
who in front like they're [ __ ] thugs
I'm not a [ __ ] thug right I'm not at
all
but because I grew up in a bad near area
I know how not to get Punk'd right I
know how not to get pushed around so
there's a couple of cats in college that
they were uh they basically said they
they rep this gang it's a very
well-known Asian gang they know for a
fact they don't
it wouldn't be any they wouldn't be in
this school yeah exactly so what the
[ __ ] are you talking about right but
they were saying they repetition and
they were like yeah they're showing tats
or whatever I was like this game doesn't
have tats it was an Asian gang unless it
said the [ __ ] actual the gang name on
it it weren't a part but he was showing
this dragon tattoo I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] this kid up he was showing a
generic dragon tattoo on his arm I'm
like that's not the game you know I mean
that's just a generic dragon tattoo long
story short these as they say would say
back in the day they were trying to test
my gangster yeah I'm not a thug but I
know when somebody else in the thug
because I'm not one even I grew up in a
very bad neighborhood I know the gang
he's talking about they don't have that
tat yeah so the guy was like long story
short but this guy he was a buddy of
mine was living with these two girls one
girl was a bisexual one would roll was a
lesbian the bisexual made out with this
guy and their lesbian relationship
became a little weird lesbian girl
decides to get this these two dudes to
come and jump him at my friend's
birthday party mm-hmm so me I'm trying
to be in this peaceful thing I actually
joined a Christian group at the time
trying to find Jesus again praise the
Lord yeah amen amen
God please bless my soul and me up there
so so we were chillin at this party and
I told this other guy I said hey I'm
just gonna say her name is Debbie and
Reyna so Debbie and Reyna right [ __ ]
those [ __ ] Hey actually Braden was
[ __ ] cute cute and she wasn't even
type of Asian but like she had like a
lip ring and she was like leaving this
punk rock type of state or whatever so
these two [ __ ] one decides to get
these two other guys one guy's name was
his name was Carl and this other [ __ ]
loser
Carl yeah Carl right yet the Carl the
thug and so
he tries to come in jump Adam at my
friend Sylvia's birthday how does your
boy yeah really nice guy he's kind of
awkward too please nice and tries to
jump at him at this point - oh and - by
the way after this Adam decides to join
jujitsu and easy don't was hell no he
they try to Punk him at this [ __ ] and
Adams a really nice dude
and so this guy Karl tries to act like
he's a [ __ ] thug small little Asian
dude of course runs up on him at the
party and then a buddy of mine had a
butterfly knife it wasn't mine and I
told him to give it to me
so I took the butterfly knife and as
he's like in [ __ ] Adams face and
Adams really quiet I literally grabbed
him by his [ __ ] throat and I put the
knife to his neck
nobody give any weapons - okay and so
like I literally put this [ __ ]
butterfly knife this is not a fake story
this is a hundred percent true you can
even ask anybody in college because when
this happened I put the knight to his
[ __ ] throat I actually didn't know
that one of my friends at the school
shout out surname was you Senya you're
saying his boyfriend boyfriend got
stabbed to death so when she saw that
[ __ ] she freaked the [ __ ] out started
screaming as she ran out of the place I
should kind of snap me out yeah and I
kind of like took the knife and I gave
it to somebody else they chucked that
they put it over my dope though I can do
a lot of tricks with that [ __ ] to his
but he got really nice are you so he got
rid of the [ __ ] knife he got rid of
the [ __ ] knife for you and I was
[ __ ] pissed in my friend Sylvia super
sweet girl Christian girl - she went to
this church called harvest out in
Riverside just add some validity just to
say yeah so she uh she grabbed me and
she told me she was David please don't
do anything please don't do anything I'm
really calm oh I'm sorry before this - I
threw the knife and hers home he trying
to sock me in the back of my head from
behind and luckily I kind of caught up
beside my he missed I swung like three
times and I popped three holes in the
wall fourth one I kept him and I busted
his [ __ ] nose there you go and and
Sylvia grabs me and she tells me like
don't do anything comment on comma of
Sylvia I promise you I'm good
I feel bad about this let's do no Carl
Carl looks over he goes that's why I
thought [ __ ] and I [ __ ] Chuck Sylvia
side I grabbed Carl I literally grabbed
him and I Chuck him so hard he flies
through the [ __ ] screen door and it
was he's through the [ __ ] screen door
Carl's just trying to test your gang and
then Carl comes up and he tries to get
up and I crack him in the nose and I
bust his [ __ ] nose too and I at that
moment I remember this feeling because I
wanted to sock him so many [ __ ] times
but because it was like you and you're
kind of skinny right in that skinny face
when he's like that size yeah and I knew
that I'm a 250-pound guy if I sock him
in the face more than once you're gonna
go to jail I'm gonna he's gonna get hurt
pretty bad he's gonna die so I decided
not to do anything I step back I chill
and they said [ __ ] you I'm gonna get my
[ __ ] sorority boys or whatever I
thought he was a thug but now he's in a
sorority home he's to come at me I was
like cool we're gonna get Kappa beta on
all over and dude so in the apartment
they had a bat so I grabbed the bat I
sat on the floor I was like I'll be
waiting for you so I just sat at the
floor waiting with a bat but then all my
friends grabbed me and they tried to
take me shoved me into a car and they
took me to my other friend Annie's
apartment and I'm trying to the whole
time I'm trying to escape out of this
[ __ ] apartment so I could go back and
I could just [ __ ] him up with his bat I
was thinking about cracking their school
until [ __ ] brain liquid came out
their [ __ ] you so can I say something
real quick yeah all of David so stories
always involve him punching a wall in
some capacity sums usually a weapon so
you know I'm sure there's a gun story
somewhere I think you told me a gun
story and the third one is there's
always a sweet young lady trying to hug
him to Gus because I hung around good
Peele always try to hang around good
they knew you were gonna be a [ __ ]
star dude nothing always hung around
really good people because I they were
the people that I wanted to be so bad
and I you know I used to get punked and
I used to get bullied and so because I
grew up in such a bad area I I knew what
I had to do so people wouldn't number
one Jack my [ __ ] take my [ __ ] money
or they're a [ __ ] yeah so I always had
to go to these like violent violent
tendencies just to be like don't [ __ ]
with me yeah but long story short with
that they kind of kept me in the
apartment and one of their sorority
brothers came in a [ __ ] motorcycle I
heard who ripped out all three of the
ripped out a stop sign and they threw it
to my friend's apartment window so that
[ __ ] made me even more angry so I
don't even know I did this in jail
killed somebody dude I did not let's so
like someone is dead because I did this
in blind rage and just to go back to the
story of why I'm Tom I this guy's a
really good
dude no no he won't sound like a good
dude because of what he was about to do
so he this guy was kind of thuggish yeah
told this guy what happened he was cool
I'm ready to go I didn't even know ttg
right there hey you know what I mean
right train to go baby
so what was happening about bad action
about but I
he was the thug I wasn't I was he was a
friend and he was just always a good
friend of me you know he's like I think
he like like we protected me a lot too I
talking about the situation he did an
angry cursing up a storm I don't even
know but four hours later he was already
in a car with like a few other dudes
with body bags and a whole bunch of
[ __ ] cats so he was gonna murder this
guy for me body bag and he was gonna
murder this guy for me and bury this
[ __ ] for me and I didn't know
that what I was saying cuz I was so
[ __ ] angry and I remember he called
me he goes yo I'm about two and a half
hours out and this is from Sacramento
all the way to LA and to Riverside and I
was like eh bro I need you to turn back
around like it's not that serious he
goes you sure cuz I'll move it's not
it's done and I started getting scared
because I'm like this guy's gonna murder
so the normal David I'm like this guy's
gonna [ __ ] more I've never actually
told the story before this is Mary all
know that story
no she doesn't well she will find out
now yeah but oh yeah I never told this
story before but I got so [ __ ] scared
because they were gonna kill somebody
yeah and like I said when you grow up in
a bad neighborhood you just happen to be
I want to say fortunate but you grow up
with other people who are thugs and
because I'm friends with them since we
were younger I just happened to be in
their good graces but can I say
something though yeah those guys that
did all that [ __ ] kind of deserve to
like if you're doing [ __ ] like that and
you're like wrecking people's houses and
don't stop signs no no you're trying to
pick fights with everyone and your five
- you kind of deserve to be wiped off
the face of the earth because though
earth does not need people like that cuz
we obviously have enough of that because
that same guy is buying all the [ __ ]
toilet paper yeah that same type of
[ __ ] guy but I like that because you
knew that he was a good friend to have
like in that situation well you know
he's gonna have your [ __ ] exactly
that's why we're still friends till this
time he still has his like thug like
tennis yeah but he's still a really
really good dude he doesn't do that type
of [ __ ] anymore because we're not old
but
to go back like a lot of he needs to he
could [ __ ] John with some of but you
know just case in point that's why I say
he's like a really good dude no matter
what I needed even he knew I was a dweeb
he was like yo somebody's [ __ ] with
my friend because he's a little [ __ ]
and now I gotta handle this [ __ ] and so
like in that type of situation to like I
like I just hated the fact I knew for a
fact because I was a fat dude with
classes and [ __ ] like he'd not he could
[ __ ] Punk me even it was him and his
friend it was two dudes yeah it's like
not you can't do that I grew up in a way
worse situation yeah so yeah I like
friends like that cuz like even for me
when I have homies like that like I said
once before I know I have the good set
of friends because it's to the point
with me where I don't care if my friend
doesn't like somebody or if they have
beef I'm not gonna I'm not gonna [ __ ]
with that person either and that's just
how I've always grown up in the sense of
that so like example like if say Nick
dated this girl for like two weeks and
she's free and she won't and I would
never that's all limits for me 100% or
if Nick just liked somebody off limits
for me that's how I've always been and
and I know that and that's how me and
all my homies are and it for example
like my friend Nick I have basically two
of my best friends in the world like our
Nick and Thomas back in Arizona I have a
couple other friends too if they listen
to this they're gonna like me but I'm
talking about a certain situation right
we had to my best friends Nick and
Thomas we had a we had an old friend
knocking to say his name but he went to
jail right did a bunch of [ __ ] but he
was really close to us so we used to
keep him there and there was one point
where he came out of prison and uh
what's it called and he was staying at
Nick's house and Nick's mom is she's a
g2 she's [ __ ] awesome she used to
always let us stay at the house and do
stuff she let him stay there right so
knowing the situation about this he was
supposed to be going to do his [ __ ]
right because I'm if you go to prison
you have to do checkups and [ __ ] like
that he stopped doing them and we knew
everybody knew that this person he was
back in trouble right like he was
getting look for and all that type of
stuff the parent knew that as well too
but she still let him stay at the house
right so this is how much we all were
friends right
how are we
so Nick lets him stay there all that
type of stuff all this [ __ ] right later
on this guy goes back to jail
whatever maybe three four years ago
three or four years ago I go back to
Arizona he gets out and he's like hey I
want to see you right
and during this time because he is a
good friend and I I usually I like to be
a good friend right he he would text me
or he would call me through there and I
would send him money right and I didn't
used to tell people that but I used to
send him money like if I could send him
50 bucks a hundred bucks stuff like that
if I had more money I would send him
more money because this was my homie
right but so he gets out again and he
starts hanging out with everybody and I
remember going talking to my friend
Thomas and I was like hey what what's up
with this person like have you heard
from I ever heard anything he's all I
never told you right it's like what's up
he was like so Nick's mom I guess got
home the house was broken into all of
her jewelry was stolen damn everything
was stolen and I was like it was him
he's like guy was him I'm my [ __ ] so
Nick obviously doesn't like him right so
I already know Nick would do the same
thing for me nobody [ __ ] likes this
kid no more right it doesn't matter he
could come and explain why he did and I
know why he did it right because he was
in the best part needing money but it's
like I don't give a [ __ ] if if Nick at
the end of the day was like hey we're
gonna go do something with this I would
go with him great that's how I am and
that's cuz they're my we've been through
a lot of [ __ ] together [ __ ] right same
thing with Nick that's why I like having
those types of friends like what you
have is like no matter what we ride or
die for each other and that's how it
always be but that [ __ ] I remember when
that [ __ ] happened I'm it's it's crazy
and that and it sucks because I kind of
brought that person around the group I
was friends with him and so like I was
kind of like [ __ ] man because we have
such a tight-knit friendship and I kind
of brought this person in there and it
was cool everything was cool and then he
[ __ ] it up right at the end but yeah
this is this is just a ramble story but
I was telling that's why I like having
friends like that it's always good to
have friends like that I think like when
you kind of grow up in a not-so-nice
area a lot of a lot of the friendships
that I have had growing up with a lot of
people who were bro
loyalty is all we had yeah that's all we
got you know there isn't
I don't know nice cars or also the [ __ ]
that kind of like people can relate to
like there's nothing that we could share
with each other besides our friendship
and loyalty yeah and so that kind of
runs really deep sometimes it gets
people in really really bad trouble
because they'll do dumb [ __ ] just
because they're your homies which I
won't do but you know I should have
rephrase obviously if Nick's like hey
we're gonna go murder so yeah that's not
gonna happen all right then but I would
always be there for Nick and Thomas no
matter what right you no matter what I
don't matter if if something were to
happen to Nick and they needed me out to
Arizona I would drop my plans go to
Arizona something were to happen to
Thomas or even my other home Lee Lewis
and that's how I know they're true
homies right because I left when I left
all the people that I thought I was
friends I don't talk to anymore
yeah and like a lot of people don't know
my Arizona California story but it was
super unexpected like I [ __ ] I moved
here on a weeks notice I told everybody
on the Sunday before I moved here but I
had all these groups of friends and then
slowly over time like all of a sudden
everybody started disappearing everybody
started disappearing and I always tell
people this to this day I talked to
maybe two just three people in Arizona
and that's not an exaggeration and I
remember when I used to go back to I
used to try and force myself to like oh
I'm gonna go hang out with these groups
I'm gonna go let me and it kind of
turned to that and I remember as I got
older obviously as getting older I was
going out there my dad's excited to see
me right because I moved to a different
state and I'm his youngest son right and
I was barely seeing him and then I
spaghetti all over yeah but I use it
spaghetti but I used to like see him in
I would go out there and see him for a
day and they just always just hang out
with my friends yeah and this is how I
knew what I like I said I had good
friends because they understood if I had
to go out there and I started telling my
hey look I'm going out here I'm only
gonna be hard for four days I want to
see my dad I'm not gonna see you guys
this time but I will see you next time
they had no issue with it yeah other
friendships started just to fade away
because of that type of [ __ ] right so
it's stuff like that but I like like
hearing stories like that because then
you know like people it's always good to
have those like
writer dive friends I guess not we're
gonna go [ __ ] hit a lick or [ __ ]
go murder somebody or something like
that but somebody and you know is always
gonna be there for you and [ __ ] and
that's kind of like and just to give
reference to that story the reason why
he came to I guess kill somebody because
I'm pretty I'm sure in my room when I
look back it I'm pretty sure in my
rambling I was telling him about him
saying he was a part of a set so it you
know it was like something like that
yeah because he wouldn't just come out
and just start [ __ ] often people he's
just what I was telling this guy that
you were he was in a gang he's probably
gonna do something to you but in his
defense he deserved it yeah for sure
I think the guy the guy was being a
those guys deserve I mean he was also
trying to Punk this do to Adam because
he knew that Adam wasn't gonna do [ __ ]
by the way the the bisexual chick is the
one that hit on him I know yeah but then
that girl that the [ __ ] hot chick
Debbie no no Reina she's the one that
that bought these two dweebs the the two
dubious [ __ ] muscle yeah to go jump
this guy and it's like it has to be the
worst huh I kill I all [ __ ] I'm gonna
bring my homies they're gonna teach a
lesson and then they get their asses by
the guy that looks like [ __ ] Hudson
yang from fresh off the boat a [ __ ]
worse they would imagine I that's why I
feel like I've always been nervous to
fight cuz my [ __ ] man our talk [ __ ] like
I try not to talk too much shaking on my
mat what if I go fight this person they
beat the living well I'm gonna tase you
I'll never fight somebody man I just
[ __ ] call the cops baby yeah it's so
hot do a lifestyle but we're gonna just
gonna hit a lick after this well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast [ __ ] yeah you need to
work on yourself this was good I like it
looks good therapy and you know what
though I think you're gonna get some
good responses from this yeah man you're
gonna get a lot of people like reaching
out to you like this kids a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think a lot of people went
through your situation yeah but once
again like if I could just say it again
you gotta fix your self-esteem first
before you get into another relationship
get it I'm getting better yeah I can
feel myself being happy I think here we
want so happier with my self-respect man
you need selfish yeah so
expect even though I did put on a little
lbs I am getting I'm starting to lift
again I'm getting stronger feeling
better about my sister's oh man I got
together with Muriel I was fatter than
you not the same weight but I had zero
strengthens our muscles at least you
have strength I had none of that [ __ ]
yeah like have you ever felt up a ziploc
bag with jello that's what my body feel
now cuz I eat that she this episode the
genius brain podcast you can find alex
on instagram at alex dot ggf Nick the
ear by the way both these guys are
personal trainers Alex specifically
specializes in powerlifting so you know
I'm saying if you check out page strong
my G's he's very strong so in the
comments below talk about what a [ __ ]
he is yeah come in that gym he showed
him hands Dane Cook and him over here
he's strength training conditioning
boxing Muay Thai and also he can do Jiu
Jitsu he just doesn't forget so he's out
looking for that for those a personal
training you got your boys over here
during this quarantine hit us up I know
a lot of people have a lot of fitness
questions and I know yeah we are open
for online coaching so hit us up mm-hmm
we would love to help out as much as we
can Gang Gang uh check them out on the
big mad podcast by the way there is
already a big mad podcast just let you
know so you should probably change that
is it it's just called big man and spelt
the normal way so alright and we might
be changing that name though okay but
thanks for having us on to day we got
you guys thanks for thanks for listeners
ramble for a fun oh thanks for listening
to my story
I feel better cuz now a lot of people
are gonna know it not just a certain
amount of groups I mean [ __ ] yes a big
stuff my boy I'm very proud dude is
therapy you guys kid feel me I'm [ __ ]
I feel like I jumped into a pole came
out of the floor just put dry clothes
over the wet clothes just so you know I
was like talk about your relationship he
started sweating immediately he was like
yeah I gotta the bathroom real quick my
[ __ ] my gallon [ __ ] hydroflax was
filled up and now it's
empty after that one conversation I job
we'll see y'all back guys